you know you had
actually some very contentious
conversations
with um with a handful of black people
and this is within the documentary and
accidental courtesy if you guys have not
seen it
please check this out it's incredible a
couple young guys
there was an older guy and uh i think
you were in a bar or a restaurant you
were sitting at a table
and these guys would not shake your hand
they walked off on you they yelled at
you
um why are black people so angry towards
you
those particular ones because i also
have a lot of black support clearly
clearly you have a lot of supporters
white black even green martians can
understand
what you're bringing to the table here
exactly uh because
ignorance ignorance you know uh
not being able to get up get out and
about and explore different people
and and find other ways of of combating
racism uh and here's the thing
um you were dealing in in that
particular scene
which took up about eight or nine
minutes in the movie right that scene
actually actually went on for just over
an
hour but of course we couldn't include
the whole hour of it
it almost became physical and you know
that that's that's how contentious it
was
who did it almost become physical with
uh myself and
and and the three of the three people
the two young guys the two young guys as
well as the older guy because one of the
guys said we're about the same age buddy
you know
and then there's the two younger guys
who felt like you were out of touch or
something
well they all did yeah and uh because
they had not been exposed to the things
that they've been exposed to
their knowledge was very limited but i
can tell you this they you know
they were the baltimore chapter of black
lives matter
and and i don't want to paint a broad
brush because
uh black lives matter is not an
organization it's a movement
and there are many many over 90 factions
across the country
of this movement and they each are
individual some are comprised of black
supremacists
some are comprised of predominantly
white people some
are comprised of black and white some
have an agenda
of aggression uh others have an agenda
hey then let's sit down and try to work
this out and drop some
some legal bills and pass etc so you
have all different
you know matters um there are about five
or six
chapters across the country that have
contacted me
and said hey do you give workshops can
you teach us how to do what you do
and then there are other chapters where
something just rip me a new one because
you know they can't stand me because i'm
sitting down talking with the enemy
i'm talking with the oppressors and
things like that i'm treating them
with respect the fact that i treat them
with respect i treat anybody with
respect
okay until they put their hands on me
then it's a whole new ballgame
but while you know people have we have
to respect
someone's right to say what they want to
say we don't have to respect what they
say
but let's respect their right to say it
because if you want to be heard
you have thought that you have to hear
the other people too you don't have to
agree with them
but you must give them a chance to voice
their opinions
and that's what i do because once
they're heard
and i allow them to be heard rather than
shut them down
and push back then when what when they
are heard
their wall comes down and they feel
compelled now hey
this guy my enemy let me you let me save
my peace even though i'm insulting him
to his face
so now their wall is down and they
reciprocate and allow me to save my
peace
when i say my peace they're hearing me
because their defense mechanism is down
you know but when it's up you can talk
all you want it's just you know
they're like this it's a brick wall so i
allow them to speak
in that space and then they allow me to
be to be heard
and that's when they go home and think
about what i've said
and it works on them and over time they
realize you know what i need to change
my direction
that's how people change you know you
can legislate all day long
you can legislate and compel somebody's
behavior
but you cannot legislate somebody's
feelings
just like you know the bus boycott right
white people did not want us in the
front of the bus
uh you know when the when the law
changed you know that we could sit
wherever we wanted to sit
that compelled them to let us sit there
even though they didn't like it they
didn't feel that we should sit there
they had to abide by the law otherwise
they'd be the one in jail not rosa parks
so respect a willingness to less a
willingness to listen well let me put it
this way
between traveling as a child and now as
an adult musician
around the world i have been in 57
different countries
on six continents so i've been exposed
exposed to a multitude
of ethnicities colors of skin cultures
traditions
religions you name it and
no matter how far i've gone from this
country no matter how
different a person may look or
or their culture may be from mine i've
concluded at the end of the day
we all are human beings and we all want
basically the same four or five things
no matter how far away we are in this
country
we want to be loved we want to be
respected
we want to be treated fairly we want to
be heard
and we want the same things for our
family as anybody else wants for their
family
and if we can understand those simple
simple five
human things no matter what culture we
go into
no matter how far away from our own
country we can navigate that culture
so if you view white supremacists
as simply another culture and you apply
those five things you will you will make
a connection you will be able to
navigate with them
and be able to have discourse civil
discourse
that's some powerful stuff right there
daryl well okay what you know i've
proven that it works
yes you have and so i'm not knocking
what anybody else does because there are
many facets to racism
and what they do they're addressing you
know one facet
of the police and systemic racism etc
and that's great you know that needs to
be done also
but we also need to address the
individual races
and that's what i do i sit down and have
a heart to heart
face to face head to head talk with them
right
with the keys with them not about them
not at them
not past them but with them and that's
what creates
change that's awesome that's a great
segue to obviously jumping into that
side of things just so
before we move on to that i want to
recap what you just said
because i don't want to just jump right
over that everyone
in the world craves these five things
yes right to be loved to be respected
to be treated fairly to be
heard and everyone wants the same thing
for their family
those five things yeah did i say that
right
absolutely everything everybody wants
something for their family that you want
for yourself
you